on peut commencer soufi vous êtes prête
revenons en arrière
où étiez vous avant
et encore avant
vous avez plonge encore à fond
vous pouvez aller plus loin
vous vous rendez compte de ce que c'est
que de ne rien se rappeler du tout
tout le monde me dépeint la personne
qu'ils croient que je suis à notre
nouvelle vie si ma vie écrit aussi
parfaite que ça pourquoi j'ai voulu en
finir
écoutez sophie le temps de tourner la
page et venir mais je veux savoir ce qui
s'est vraiment passé ça nous l'avons
compris et nous croyons l'avoir compris
pc basés uniquement sur ce qu'on croit
savoir de ce qui s'est passé
et si je n'avais pas sauté
vous n'avez rien vu ou entendu de
curieux en sauvant ce jour là vous étiez
choqué ce que vous racontiez était
incohérent vous disiez qu'un homme vous
avez poussé du bateau est votre
véritable nom n'était pas celui sur
votre pièce d'identité
des personnes avec une vie parfaite
comme la tienne c'est rare qu'elles
plongent d'un ferry mon mari a menti sur
son alibi au jour de l'accident tu
commençais à me souvenir de certaines
choses j'imagine que ça doit être
vraiment
c'est dur d'ignorer les secrets de son
existence
on peut pas simplement faire semblant
d'être une nouvelle personne
et que le passé n'existe pas
[Musique]
alors tu te souviens vraiment de rire
mon mari dit les parce que tu crois
pourquoi tu as menti elle commence à
poser des questions auxquelles je veux
pas répondre peut-être que je me trompe
sur toute la ligne
sophie qu'est-ce que tu veux savoir rien
je reconstitue le puzzle